in today's morning rounds this flu
season is on track to be one of the
worst in recent history in terms of the
number of people infected flu is now
widespread in almost every single state
and nearly 10 million people have become
ill so far 4800 of those people have
died pediatric deaths are double what
they were this time last year and dr.
taryn Narula is here to help us
understand why so 32 children have died
so far from the flu this year why is it
up so much so it's interesting this year
you know the word we use about the flu
is unpredictable and it's been
unpredictable because we've seen a shift
in the predominant strain which is
usually influenza A this year it's
influenza B that hasn't happened since
the 1992-1993 flu season and we know
that influenza B tends to affect
children more they tend to have more
severe reaction to influenza B than the
older one of the more serious
complications that you get so certainly
pneumonia is one of the most serious and
most frequent complications they can
also get encephalitis which is swelling
at the brain they can also develop
sinusitis or ear infections then there
can be things like seizures or
myocarditis which is inflammation of the
heart rate about a little girl going
blind that's right you know you have an
incident your own house we do we were
away I kept the flu shot my daughter had
the flu shot
she she's seven she got the flu while we
were away on Christmas break and as she
was recovering we thought oh she's
getting better she came into my room at
night and said I can't walk my legs hurt
she was crawling to the back at which
point we discovered that in fact viral
Myositis or inflammation of the muscles
of the legs can happen in children what
you're those runner doctor we are and it
was so scary and this is why it's so
important to remind parents that this
doesn't have to just be oh a fever and
some respiratory symptoms this can
progress this can be deadly so what
should parents be looking for so
certainly you want to look for the signs
of the food right so fever abrupt onset
cough runny or stuffy nose sore throat
headache muscle aches but also in
children they can have things like
stomach pains or nausea and vomiting and
diarrhea abdominal symptoms and then you
want to recognize when things might be
getting worse so if the kid complains of
muscle aches or pains if they look like
their lips or skin are turning blue
they're having respiratory difficulties
their fevers very high or their mental
state or
this really changes you need to seek
care and call your doctor and as you
pointed out this thing look can look
like it's going away and then it can
suddenly roar back the flu shot dr. Tara
Narula thanks
you